aujourd'hui nous sommes aux universités
d'été de la baule nous sommes à la baule
pour les exercer tvt des républicains en
loire atlantique réunie autour de bruno
retailleau et des ténors de retailleau
qui a convié françois fillon alors gpu
nicolas sarkozy cette réunion elle a
pris un tournant nationale genou dans un
esprit de rassemblement pour voir les
politiques parler et leur discours pour
voir les jeunes qui sont venus
aujourd'hui
pour parler de militantisme c'est une
sentiment d'unité d'union à travers le
party les républicains
on reste unis autour d'un objectif les
régionales et la reconquête l'unité
bruno n'est pas un choix c'est une
obligation si on veut être digne d une
vis à vis de ceux qui vous font
confiance
dean vis-à-vis de son pays digne des
gares aux responsabilités qu'on porte
sur nos épaules
la dignité nous oblige à l'unité cette
union vous l'apporter au fond du coeur
et si vous êtes aussi nombreux c'est
pour nous donner ce message vous voulez
que le mouvement sous la pression de
président se rassemblent se réunissent
pour gagner ces élections régionales
rassembler rassembler
les tables rondes peuvent emmener
vraiment le sujet sur le sur le débat
d'idées
je pense qu'on a besoin d'hommes
courageux je pense qu'on a besoin de
guide est novatrice
qu'est ce que j'ai pu entendre des
projets sur le chômage sur les routes
mais sur des impôts dans l'actualité la
crise des migrants qui tragédie les
problèmes de la france chômage
tout est public formation à deux
vitesses il faut vraiment mettre en
place un système qui permette aux jeunes
de rester chez nous et puis ben que
qu'on puisse travailler gagner sa vie
voilà c'est tout gagner sa vie
honnêtement et puis être heureux dans un
pays qui est beau quand même nous sommes
les amis les héritiers d'une histoire
immense qui nous convient à regarder
vers le haut en rassemblant de force
durant des siècles nos ancêtres ont
travaillé dur pour faire la france un
grand pays un pays progrès est un pays
de liberté au pays civilisation si vous
avez choisi de nous rejoindre c'est
parce que vous avez compris qu'on a
besoin de vous on a besoin de vous pour
construire la besoin de vous pour
construire la france du xxième siècle
vive les républicains vive la république
et vive la france